you've said i saw in an interview that
the exorcist i'm going to quote you
should not focus on the manifestations
of evil but focus on the power of god
that is at work
that sounds great how does that
translate does that mean that
when a demon is manifesting you're kind
of ignoring the antics and just going
about the prayer and is that
that's got to be really challenging in
the moment to not like whoa there's
somebody in the air
you know i can't imagine that but
explain to people what that means a
little bit about not focusing on what
the devil is doing and staying really
like laser focused on your role
a good analogy would be apparent with
their child and the child is throwing a
temper tantrum
but the parent doesn't feed into it
lets the child do have the temper
tantrum but
doesn't react
because
just as much as the child having the
temper tantrum once a reaction
the demon through these manifestations
once a reaction
so i've learned over the years i just
don't feed into it
so a good example i'll give so we
mentioned levitation earlier so in one
of the exorcisms in rome
you know 17 years ago when i was there
the uh
the person began to levitate
and as i'm looking at this in in
disbelief
i was more impressed by father carmine
so as the person begins to levitate he's
looking out of the corner of his eyes
he's praying he never stops praying but
he reaches over and puts his hand on the
head of the person
and pushes them back down into the chair
so he never once paused in the prayer of
the church
and i've what i learned from that lesson
was
kind of the mentality really is that all
you got because i'm not impressed right
right so then you would have to walk
into that room with the belief you would
have to actually walk through life with
the belief that no demon or no presence
of evil would be too powerful for god to
handle absolutely because you know the
the demons are still creatures
they're more powerful than humans but
they're still creatures and no creature
can be greater than the creator
god himself have you encountered people
faking
uh possession and
or trying to
convince you they're possessed and
something just doesn't look right is
there a test that you administer like do
you use fake holy water and throw it at
them and they're like ah you're like
okay this is not a real like how do you
how do you assess that other than just
you know you talked about the psych
evaluation and you talked about a
medical examination but how do you
assess that
if um
if it's a faker or not
so i do some of the things you suggested
sometimes i sprinkle people with water
that's not been blessed so it's not holy
water
so i know whether or not it's been
blessed the demon will know because of
the sacred character but the person as
an individual will not
so again i do these things to get back
to that moral certitude beyond a doubt
this person truly is possessed and i've
had people that have tried to fake it
some deliberately
meaning they're trying to make a mockery
of the church right some people do it
indirectly just because they're dealing
with
maybe some mental health issues
i remember there was a uh
a priest back at my diocese and
i went to his parish and he wanted me to
evaluate somebody that the mother
brought in about this young boy and
and during our conversation the boys
started rolling all over the floor and
whatnot
and then uh the priest says to me well
obviously this person is possessive like
no that person is not possessed
[Music]
and then i went back probably about a
year later for another person
and then during the conversation there
was a little not much and he says to me
well that person is not possessed i said
no that person is possessed
so some of that is just
wisdom that comes with time
and even before i meet with somebody i
will spend time in prayer just asking
god to
guide and direct me in the best way to
help this person and to know whether or
not this is truly something demonic i'm
going to do one more question before we
head to the chat and then i have more
after that so tyler just if you can
check that out um
does possession always manifest in
what we see in the movies or is it
possible that possession could manifest
in just evil for example you know and i
know i think pat brought this up to you
yesterday in your interview
asked a question related to you know why
don't you see big athletes or big you
know people well known that are
undergoing possession
is it possible though that possession
could take a form of maybe your eyes
don't go green you don't levitate but
you
behave in a way that is
evil
um unpleasant damaging to others
could a random person who commits murder
be
possessed but not manifesting in a way
that would make for a great movie how do
you feel about that broader
definition of possession
i would say that manifestations indicate
that there's an internal
struggle taking place
so the person is dealing with the
demonic but they don't want it they want
to reject it
and that's what causes the
manifestations it could be that somebody
is dealing with the demonic but there is
no internal struggle
and because of that there would be no
manifestations
the church would even say there's
something that we would call perfect
possession
where the individual has united their
will with the will of the demon i mean
obviously the goal
in the spiritual life and the life of
faith would be to unite our wills with
the will of god
but there are people that would unite
their wills with the will of the devil
and when that happens there would be no
internal struggle
so there would be no need for
manifestations if you like the short
clip you can catch another one here or
you can catch the full episode right
here
you